so I really really enjoy jason's
gameplay I've always a player who really
enjoys kind of like weird gimmicks the
characters have and I believe to employ
because I'm you know tricky about the
best at combos at that times as you've
seen on this game but Jason really
matches how I play so I'm very excited
to show him off so you can just drop
combos with him and then it just
eventually puts another combo up is that
not quite you still get to be so we're
gonna go ahead and get started on to
show some Jason here reverently so we
got slasher Jason right this is his
first variation very first variation so
what the start off what's kind of common
between all the variations I know that
Jason really doesn't have too much but
would would be a few things that you
come well he has a shoulder charge and
so in this trade it's kind of like a big
ol wrestling style shoulder charge brute
force Sarah root and then the other
variations it's kind of like a
clothesline was a retro almost like a
wrestling style clothesline and one
thing it's also with Jason is a lot of
his fight style is pretty much
traditional across all variations except
for this one yes and in this variation
his moveset is very focused on the
machete you're going to get the
extension of the machete the damage with
the machete lots of blood and then
machete Oni variation specials take over
I love liked it i I've Yoda I'm gonna
play with there's two variations I've
been practicing with this I'm slasher
and the next one will show this one it's
great because first of all your neutral
jump is so good like such a good way
yeah way more reach you also we have to
some practice mode so you guys can
actually see how some moves hit and
whatnot um he like just like an e5 again
you won't always know highs and lows
they have extra stuff and yes yes he has
those he's got a great low overhead he's
off
quit overhead oh yes so yeah we wanted
to make sure at least you know while
we're practicing show you what kind of
attractions are so if it's an overhead a
mid just give you guys quick glance of
how he bites right and like was like
another kind of shared move he does have
like in the variations he has a choke
yes now in this one he is still sort of
a joke but he also adds a big a little
Jason as well Jason stabby stabby right
right and my favorite is the the meter
bird version you can be got just the
animation here Oh too much look we
didn't check out the other one yeah oh
that's right
well that's right it is so that he also
has you know a sweet slash move what you
could add add to like the end of
compound a good combo and it also this
is just a blood off the old image plot
on the shaker Jason Jason quickly okay
I like to keep the stuff clean yeah I
also like the little tiny touch was to
like his throw in this variation
different yes yes this is a different
room oh hey I love so holux fine how it
really does embody a lot of like the
Jason movies right like it's almost like
you lived watching them for you hey like
I can finally use this move yes
if I go too far right yeah yeah now my
favorite thing the J stands right now
that I use a lot in this is I want to
explain this well to the fan so they
really understand how this works and
it's not like an Opie thing but it's
like super cool risk/reward type of
movement so we have this Derrick is
still doing little damage but I can't be
here now during that time after it's
over your owner of us free hit so it's a
very big risk reward but if you do it at
the right time in the fight you're going
to dominate right if you're if you're
super low on health and you do it you
might be a little bit of trouble to
really get your lead and push your meat
it's a really good thing to do so you
can do stuff like you'll get it he'll
come in try to hit me
missed it ah just aren't eatin an item
my goal is always to try to knock him
down at the m yes so that my fall asleep
has a little less time for a full combo
yeah and try and knock him all the way
across range something like that yeah so
the shoulder charge would really help it
yeah situation so you get your goals
pretty much it becomes a meta game with
Jason of how you're able to keep that
thing up and then um one other he's also
got a projectile in this variation as
well is awesome for Jack tile oh you'll
notice I cannot dump it isn't it
but you can jump in though there's also
if we do this real quick let's move here
mm-hmm
going to your x-ray it will break your
little break there so there are things
that you can do but the other thing is
to if Jason is to use his x-ray during
that section
sorry the other day he doesn't fall
asleep yeah but also something that you
did not mention yeah you can't jump okay
right so it's a negation gets a little
bit more limited while he's in this as
well so I mean he's not completely like
tagged right you deal with the
teleporter you have some problems you
deal the personally Derek I was playing
earlier and he was just jumping back and
forth yeah on the pillars and I
understand yeah oh the coab and just
joke back and forth I can do thing about
right so uh it becomes a juggernaut so
yeah definitely like a really good
players look is awesome is there
anything else special to this variation
that we should probably go over no you
guys pretty much covered it on that
nailed it oh cool boss I'm a fairly
utilizes machete and impossible and they
reach to like I think the region is
really amazing I even the low
alright save a little bit for later
oh yeah alright cool so um got ya
nope nope just go to your practice
option oh we there we go go ahead we're
to go to which ruined Lister impossible
yeah there it is
here it is really god bless practice
mountain yeah I think it is lit there we
will show you some introductions later
as well because for the belt match today
we'll talk about later I will be playing
Jason we'll talk about your stuff later
but I will be playing Jason all right so
here's relentless and you'll notice that
his mask has changed based on his
variation so it's a darker chrome color
yes as a Jason like so you know dress up
once in a while so this movie did this
this were like what I read about this we
were doing and he's just he's got
command grab based and teleports I was
like oh my that's me
wait I did that good thing that I
haven't played slasher more but I'm
gonna learn this one next brown so let's
kind of talk about husband works let's
start with the big one yeah the big one
is the teleport this yeah likeness so
you can be exit to get the armor and
also come out a little bit faster as
well
miss terrifying because he's always
behind you that like the movie that is
truly what I'd really love about the dis
dis design is because there's a lot of
things involved in this design like even
doing this it's like he's walking
towards you this is like the movie right
you can't kill him right just stay away
please just stay away until he falls
right
so yeah the lateness is awesome he also
has a type of choker yeah and so that's
a joke in this variation match their
necks
yeah whatever you want to call this one
you can really start utilizing those
command grab specials off of teleport oh
the bear hug fudge is like shooting out
of his eyes it's such like a whole
that's awesome it's so great who I've
been doing with them as I'll do this
know what my bridging watch a meter burn
my throw so they have a hit on it and
they'll still get comma then you just
love that next yeah he's so gentle
backbreaker got another BAM good ad this
one's not enough Kali
oh let's do the UH stay right there okay
full screen alright so instead of a
solar barge
I am the clothesline baingan or oh
that's that's not it fit wheat there you
go here Oh little Jason take their
movies released in 2005 awesome
and like we talked about too with these
reducible to dare to serve is uh I jump
in sub-zero at you
I won't talked about before is like all
of these characters are fully fleshed
out characters they have brutalities
they have fatality yes the other things
again with as well um so they are
they're full full character yep
absolutely
oh we forgot one thing yeah what do we
forget this variation also has the
pursuit pursuit yeah do tell what does
that go so what happens is is the when
Jason activates it the opponent's attack
buttons will be a little discombobulated
with you then Jason can get in there and
start doing this pressure utilize that
with the teleport because his mother
India the the buns are flipped down like
yeah right yeah baseball so switch so
you can also you can do like this is
great it does feel like the movie but I
can do like this it's gonna take some
time I can't even get way don't know
them now you just leave ghostly chase
but if you hit Jason and that's that
that's they eat it will kill get some
yeah it automatically stops if you guys
get yeah so that's a we've one more
thing go ahead and jumping me okay huh
thank got that well anti-air not this it
again yeah that's his anti you're
throwing there's a hard knock down for
the Bluebird gets hard knockdown that's
a little bit of a sleeping bag oh my
also and his drone is now I think I saw
that Freddie restore yes that's Freddie
trick there it is
alright let's uh let's go to the last
one huh yeah why we just do it through
regular versus so we can hear you know
some intros here J as much Jason talks
yeah here's some long prose by Jason
awesome
ah oh I remember them trying to eat them
at my Hotmail outside one of years yeah
it's out there now unstoppable
unstoppable um all right one of my
favorites
he's because he's usually a good jerk
and most of his intro alright I love how
he just looks at them too so Jason and
you'll notice is a visual difference as
the chain around is yes for this one yep
this one's super cool and this is gonna
go
sorry investor rock during the interest
you better bring it
Rick me for Jason also likes to not talk
during the okay so here is a unstoppable
Jason what we talk about here Evan
alright so this line huh
you get a regeneration type of upturn
instead of the stoppable juggernaut
right but you do get the rapid damage
buff which will cause the change in a
low and right there you can start
utilizing some heavy damage combo
command grab specials so he's got this
one which will you see glow that gives
him some life back and you'll see in the
upper corner there maybe you can
actually be exit again you have to wait
sighs wait so close and then you've got
another yeah outside maybe and then it
goes will faster yeah gets real fast
yeah and you can attack obviously what
is going on so you know if you're able
to punish him alive you can regain some
nice type of help right and then here we
also your talked about is he has this
wears chain will glow channeling out
you see the special paying effect there
and now the damage output is greater
yeah and before let's go over whatever
his next more passive uh special ability
in this variation
you can't kill Jason GameChanger so
whatever Jason has whatever amount of
meter he has will directly go up to his
bar once he died right if he has no
meter left he still will come back with
both fiber somehow yeah right and it's
full it's about what is it but I'd say
huh 220 between 15 yeah you're on there
Athena 20 yep so you're always going to
watch out at the end of the round to
make sure you close it out and games
like porn yeah definitely at least get
yourself in good position and get ready
uh so don't think let's just go it
that's not good that's pretty much it
for this version of Jason right yeah he
still has the same command grab special
variation this is for a player who
there's a different style pic and his
resurrection will happen in both routes
yeah so it's not just a one-round of
different goal price right now you do it
fetus what size what I'm going to show
me if a calorie um I'll show him come
gymnix at least threatening your that
directions Oh Oh Jason show yeah you're
getting there after like 14 pound back
out guru started with disabilities are
about there's no scrip - well that is
driven yeah I love Jason too because as
a player it's like he's a very rich
bulwark character and I think a lot of
rich to a very rare reward but in this
one he has a lot of really good armory
I'm so he's got a rushing down its wake
up arm around a lot of his attacks to
was for a guy who's got like super combo
heavy is really helpful for Russia right
right but you can rush down players so
you're really but you can easily punish
it as well if I try to do too much see
what you do which I oh there we go
Oh
Jason and I also like the fact that
during that fatality it had that like
horror film just done and he was looking
up like no don't kill me it's so
perfectly I love so many other design
things for Jason is because it does feel
so movie based I can feel you